[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier ist Tatort Deutschland der tägliche
True Crime Podcast von Bild mit mir im
Studio ist Mirko Kasimir und bei mir zu
meiner großen Freude Toni Heier hallo
Toni hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und
Zuhörer worum geht es heute um Onkel Tic
Tac auch bekannt als das Sandmännchen na
das klingt doch mal deutlich weniger
blutrünstig als die Blutgräfin oder der
Menschenfresser aber Toni ich vermute
ganz stark dass der Schein trügt oder oh
ja mein lieber eigentlich haben wir uns
alle mal so eine nette harmlose
Geschichte verdient aber naja hier geht
es nun mal um Verbrechen und hinter
Onkel tick tack bzw dem Sandmann
verbirgt sich ein Massenmörder der
mindestens 12 Kinder im Alter zwischen
fünf und 13 Jahren ermordet hat und das
sind nur die Fälle für die er verurteilt
wurde der Schweriner Kriminalist Michael
Stricker sagte dem NDR
haben heute insgesamt 20 Morde
nachgewiesen werden können und das ist
wahrscheinlich sogar bis zu 100 Kinder
waren die dem Mann mit dem niedlichen
Spitznamen zum Opfer fielen ja ja von
wegen Onkel Tic Tac von wegen
Sandmännchen Adolf Seefeld so sein
richtiger Name ist einer der schlimmsten
Serienmörder Deutschlands aber natürlich
gibt es Gründe für diese Namen Mirko
nimm uns mit in die frühen 30er Jahre
sie sahen aus wie kleine Engelchen so
wird später jemand berichten man findet
sie im Kiefer Schonungen oder im Schilf
kleine Jungs in den damals so beliebten
matrosenanzügen es scheint als hätten
sie sich zum Schlafen niedergelegt ihre
Augen sind geschlossen ihnen scheint
nichts zu fehlen ein friedliches Bild
doch die Kinder die Förster und
Suchtrupps immer wieder in Mecklenburg
in Brandenburg und Ostholstein finden
sind tot der Sandmann geht um
die Namen haben ihm die Ermittler
gegeben weil seine Opfer aussehen als
seien sie friedlich eingeschlafen
niemand weiß woran sie gestorben sind
oft werden sie in den kalten
Jahreszeiten gefunden mal glaubt man sie
seien erfroren mal sie seien an einer
Pilzvergiftung gestorben aber im Laufe
der Zeit wird dann doch klar dass es
sich um Morde und einen Serientäter
handelt
jetzt gehen die Ermittler davon aus dass
die Kinder erstickt oder vergiftet
wurden aber auch etwas gewagtere
Theorien werden diskutiert hat der Täter
seine Opfer hypnotisiert um sich
ungestört an ihn Vergehen zu können und
hat er sie dann einfach nicht aus der
Trance geweckt sondern im Wald
zurückgelassen wo sie ohne wieder
aufzuwachen erfrieren mussten
mit endgültiger Sicherheit wird die
Frage nie geklärt als dem Massenmörder
Adolf Seefeld 1936 der Prozess gemacht
wird gesteht und erklärt er nichts ein
Gerichtsmediziner kommt zu dem Schluss
dass die Opfer erwirkt oder erdrosselt
wurden obwohl sie keine Anzeichen
äußerer Gewalt aufweisen
erst nach seiner Verurteilung wird sie
fällt aussagen dass er mehr als 100
Kinder missbraucht und mindestens 30 von
ihnen mit Gift getötet habe ein
wertloses Geständnis das unter der
Folter der Gestapo zustande kommt
Werbung
was hat Sauce Bernaise mit Erregung
öffentlichen Ärgernisses zu tun und
kommt man wegen Oralverkehr während der
Periode in den Knast um diese und mehr
pikante Fragen geht es in der neuen
six-eigen Produktion Sex crime Stories
Paula im true crime-fieber in insgesamt
sechs Episoden trifft six sex-expertin
Paula Lambert dem bekannten
Strafverteidiger Bestsellerautor und
Podcaster dr Alexander Stevens er
berichtet von den skurrilsten
spannendsten und schockierendsten
sexuellen motivierten Fällen seiner
Laufbahn aber keine Sorge das klingt
jetzt etwas brutal aber es geht in dem
Format nicht um sexuelle Gewalt viel
mehr geht es um echte Fälle die vor
Gericht verhandelt wurden mit
überraschenden und skurrilen Wendungen
bei diesem Format verschlägt es sogar
der sonst sofortgewandten Paula Lambert
die Sprache auch ich muss sagen die
Fälle sind teilweise kaum zu glauben und
es gibt immer wieder viel zu schmunzeln
also verpasst nicht Sex crime Stories
Paula im truecrime-fieber ab 6 Februar
immer montags um 20 Uhr auf sixx
Werbung Ende
aber von Anfang an Adolf Seefeld wird am
6 März 1870 in Potsdam geboren er ist
das siebte und jüngste Kind der Familie
die Mutter verlässt die Familie der
kleine Adolf bleibt mit dem Vater und
einer lieblosen Stiefmutter zurück mit
elf Jahren wird er sexuell missbraucht
so sagte später er macht eine Ausbildung
zum Schlosser und danach zum Uhrmacher
das führt später zum gruseligen
Spitznamen des Serienmörders
Adolf Seefeld zieht nach Lübeck und
heiratet doch die Ehe hält nicht lange
er beginnt ein unstetes Wanderleben
zieht als Reisender Uhrmacher durch
Norddeutschland lebt oft für lange Zeit
im Wald und schafft es dennoch eine
gepflegte gutbürgerliche Fassade
aufrecht zu erhalten er macht in dieser
Zeit Männer Bekanntschaften doch
irgendwann vermutlich schon um die
Jahrhundertwende rum interessiert er
sich nur noch für kleine Jungen es fällt
ihm leicht das Vertrauen von Kindern zu
gewinnen
seefeld ist unscheinbar Fahndungsfotos
aus den 30er Jahren zeigen einen
freundlichen Mann mit grauem Hut und
Rucksack wir haben wahrscheinlich auch
so einem Dackelblick oder also man kann
sich ganz gut vorstellen sie harmlos er
ausgesehen haben muss wenn er lächelte
ja vermutlich war das so
der nette Onkel tick tack so nennen ihn
die Kinder und gehen mit ihm wenn er
ihnen Geschenke verspricht oder sie
einlädt gemeinsam Tiere im Wald zu
beobachten im Wald vergeht er sich dann
an ihnen man weiß nicht wie viele Jungs
ihm zwischen 1898 und den frühen 30ern
zum Opfer fallen und auch nicht wie
viele er tötet er wird mehrmals erwischt
und kommt wegen
sittlichkeitsdelikten ein Jungen so
heißt das damals ins Gefängnis verbringt
auch eine Zeit in der Psychiatrie
insgesamt 23 Jahre sitzt der ein
doch es dauert lange bis jemand erkennt
dass Onkel tick tack auch der Sandmann
ist wir sind jetzt in den Kriminalakten
ab 1935 jetzt nehmen die Ermittlungen
Fahrt auf innerhalb kurzer Zeit
verschwinden in der Gegend zwischen
Rostock und Schwerin drei Jungen und
können nur noch Tod wiedergefunden
werden alle drei tragen Matrosenanzüge
alle drei liegen in Kiefern Schonungen
wie kleine Engelchen als würden sie
schlafen die Ermittler nehmen Kontakt zu
ihren Kollegen in Berlin auf und schnell
stellt sich heraus das ist dort in
letzter Zeit einige ähnliche Fälle
gegeben hat ein intensives Aktenstudium
fördert weitere Vorfälle in Mecklenburg
Brandenburg und Ostholstein zu Tage die
meisten sind als Unfall deklariert doch
der Groschen ist gefallen von nun an
jagen die Ermittler einen Serienmörder
anfangs scheint es keine Hinweise zu
geben nicht einmal ein Motiv ist klar
man vermutet ein sexuellen Hintergrund
doch es gibt keine Anzeichen für
Missbrauch und trotzdem kann die Polizei
einen schnellen Erfolg vorweisen schon
im März 1935 wird ein Verdächtiger
festgenommen ein 40-jähriger
Handelsreisender der in der Nähe einiger
Tatort gesehen wurde aber er ist der
Falsche das wird klar als am 22 März der
elfjährige Gustav Thomas verschwindet
und am 23 März scheinbar friedlich
schlafen und in einem Kiefernwald bei
Wittenberger aufgefunden wird auch für
den unschuldig Inhaftierten kommt diese
Erkenntnis zu spät er hat sich zuvor in
seiner Zelle das Leben genommen
boah das ist echt eine bittere
Nebengeschichte in diesem Fall aber
Gustav Thomas ist das letzte Opfer von
Adolf Seefeld Zeugen haben den Jungen
zusammen mit einem älteren Mann gesehen
und können eine Beschreibung liefern
doch der wichtigste Hinweis kommt aus
Grabow einer Stadt in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ein Wachtmeister
erinnert sich dass er zwei Jahre zuvor
die Personalien eines Mannes aufgenommen
hat der zwei Jungen in den Wald locken
wollte er hat den Fall damals nicht
weiter verfolgt weil ja schließlich auch
nichts Strafbares geschehen ist
aber endlich hat die Polizei einen Namen
Adolf Seefeld und Fotos die nach
früheren Verhaftungen aufgenommen wurden
Fahndungsaufrufe werden in der ganzen
Gegend verbreitet am dritten april wird
Seefeld in einer Dorfkneipe in woodsets
im Havelland festgenommen vermutlich
mehr als 35 Jahre nach seinen ersten
Taten und nach mindestens einem Dutzend
möglicherweise bis zu 100 Morden der
Prozess beginnt im Jahr 1936 es wird ein
Indizienprozess denn See fällt selbst
verweigert die Aussage doch die Indizien
reichen aus vor allem sind da seine
Haftstrafen für sittlichkeitsdelikte und
die Tatsache dass alle bis dahin
bekannten Fälle genau in die Zeiträume
fielen in denen er auf freiem Fuß war
seine eigenen Aufzeichnungen und
Zeugenaussagen belegen dass er stets in
der Nähe war wenn ein Junge im
Matrosenanzug verschwand und später wie
schlafend im Wald gefunden wurde
Adolf Seefeld wird am 22 februar 1936
vor dem Schweriner Geschworenen Gericht
zum Tode verurteilt dann nimmt sich die
Gestapo seiner an und foltert ein
Geständnis aus ihm heraus
am 22 Mai 1936 wünscht sich Adolf
Seefeld einen gebratenes Hühnchen es ist
seine Henkersmahlzeit am nächsten Morgen
wird er mit dem Fallbeil hingerichtet
[Musik]
oh mann ey was für eine Geschichte bis
zu 100 Morde überleg dir mal so viele
Eltern die sich voller Angst gefragt
haben wo ihr Junge bleibt und die dann
die schreckliche Gewissheit ertragen
mussten dass er nie wieder nach Hause
kommen wird selbst wenn es zwölf Morde
waren ich sag hier ganz bewusst nicht
nur 12 Morde was für ein Grauen ja und
besonders verstörend finde ich die
harmlos klingenden Bezeichnungen im
Zusammenhang mit diesem Fall Onkel Tic
Tag Sandmann Engelchen mit dem Wissen
was da passiert ist hat das für mich die
Anmutung von
Kinderliedern in einem Horrorfilm das
ist einfach nur grausam voll absoluter
möchte man eigentlich gar nicht drüber
nachdenken dass diese ich sag jetzt mal
unschuldigen Begriffe so etwas Böses
hinter sich stehen haben gerne wirkliche
Horrorgeschichte
aber damit sind wir auch schon am Ende
für heute wir haben für diese Geschichte
einige sehr gute Quellen verwendet
darunter das Buch die Bestie aus dem
Wald von frankreicher Schurig und
Michael Stricker sehr hilfreich waren
mehrere Artikel der Schweriner
Volkszeitung sowie Beiträge von NDR
Fokus und Tagesspiegel wir danken euch
fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal
bei Tatort Deutschland eure Toni und
euer Marco
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heyer Script und Postproduktion